joe biden looking to crush the trucker
protest in canada before it spreads here
the president telling justin trudeau to
get tough and crack down on the freedom
convoy and white house officials are
urging canadian leaders to use their
federal powers to break up the protests
looks like they got the message ontario
declaring a state of emergency and is
demanding the truckers go home now
and justin trudeau issuing this direct
threat
we talked about the u.s based flooding
of the 911 phone lines in ottawa the
presence of u.s citizens in the
blockades
and the impact of foreign money to fund
this illegal activity everything is on
the table
because this unlawful activity has to
end
and it will
end
meanwhile the media keeps hammering the
truckers as dangerous insurrectionists
some of the organizers of this protest
which as i mentioned started more than a
week ago they do want to overthrow the
government the police chief says covet
protests are a quote nationwide
insurrection driven by madness a
nationwide insurrection driven by
madness it's not just truckers there's a
lot of i've heard there's q anon
supporters in the crowd residents that i
have spoken to who say they feel
terrorized intimidated look at them
and while the media bashes them a
reporter from barry weiss's sub stack
actually went and spoke to him turns out
it's a pretty diverse group quote i have
spoken to close to 100 protesters
truckers and other folks and none of
them sounded like an insurrectionist
white supremacist racist or misogynist
greg i think i know what we need to do
we have to liberate the truckers from
canada i say we do a full-blown invasion
into canada make canada part of the
united states i think everybody would
agree that's the right move you know
what i like the sound of that and i like
the look of that map you know uh when
justin trudeau said everything's on the
table
didn't he just suggest a willingness to
go to war because they're saying that
americans are involved so did he just
basically say let's go america uh i find
that very hard look we saw this coming
when this first started we
that it was going to be called an
insurrection on 16 wheels this is the
same demonization that the media did
with trump voters with parents at school
board meetings everybody becomes a nazi
because they can't argue with them the
first thing they do is they try the
blanket smear i mean do you really think
these are the type of people that are
going to mess with the super bowl these
are the people who watch the super bowl
and it's disgusting
that our white house is putting them on
par with terrorists i can't even name a
canadian terrorist i can name a lot of
terrorists from other countries
but i can't do it but they didn't even
do that with antifa or antifa you know
two dozen people died in the george
floyd riots they didn't get their
panties in a bunch over that but now
they're doing about
basically nobody has nobody has broken a
law except honking and then you got to
see a bona fide cnn analyst
threatening actual violence basically
trying to initiate violence by saying
slash their tires drain their gas tanks
blah blah blah imagine if they did that
that would actually initiate violence
that is an actual cnn analyst trying to
start something imagine if i said that
about blmmers oh man but the thing is
canadian truckers easy target there's no
thumbs up emoji for them you know but
then she backtracked it and said she was
just trying to talk about peaceful
protests no
she's an advocate for attacking a
peaceful protest cnn again wrong side of
history wrong side on everything it's
amazing isn't that incitement you know
go go slash their tires you know the
amazing thing about this is that canada
isn't used to this the canadians don't
protest on the level that we do in the
united states and to get these truckers
who gave everything at a time when they
didn't even know how dangerous covid was
to make them into terrorists and
insurrectionists is absolutely absurd
but what is so hypocritical i'm so tired
of using that word is for biden to call
up trudeau and say look you better make
sure you stop them trudeau didn't even
want to talk to them he might have been
able to sen to stop some of this but
right now they're now starting a protest
on foot in jericho they're calling it
the jericho protest they're protesting
around parliament and the truth is that
they're going to continue because the
world supports them and when trudeau is
talking about foreign money he's talking
about money from the united states money
from all over the world and any
government that threatens to take money
from people who give it for someone else
is committing it as committing a crime
it's a fraud it's a uh it's a larceny
geraldo i think the only answer we put a
wall up on the northern border and we
just end this right
whoever would have thought that the
southern border would be less chaotic
i i think i heard a lot of uh well
expressed uh but bogus uh analysis of
what's happening
i just got off the phone with my friend
who lives in toronto but does business
in uh in ottawa uh he says that
canadians are
you know they're nice people they they
are and and they they don't overreact
they are gratefully
or profoundly annoyed i should say that
the government has taken this long to
clean up the streets of the capital city
uh calling them truckers is very
romanticizing them they're more like
occupy wall street less than half of
them are actually i mean occupy wall
street they didn't even have a job what
would you call them there's a couple
people are truckers there's a couple of
thousands some are half of them are the
other half are are who's occupy wall
street no they support the truckers
these are hard working people these are
these are disgruntled people listen they
have whatever their beef is i i i
understand that i have no problem with
people acting out to resolve issues that
they have what i have a problem with is
when you stop trade between two nations
you put people out of work you cause
enormous only the government can do that
you put people out of work
toyota and ford are closing ships now
because they can't get parts because of
the prototype they voluntarily open one
lane on their own they don't want to
stop the pathetic thing about this is
the pathetic thing about this is that it
has been allowed to go on for over two
weeks in the can you imagine in the
capital city
closing things down annoying people to
beat the band
you know what gerald they should set
fire to buildings they did that all
summer i didn't hear you what are you
doing
where do they where do you think they go
to the bathroom it's curious where do
you think the bathrooms in those
truckers know how to do that it's lined
up all right by the way i love how you
when it comes to lockdowns and masks hey
don't stop just a little bit longer just
a little we're almost there we're almost
there
show up and you go oh my god they're
shutting things down that has to stop
right now
[Music]
to call closing some lanes on a bridge
an act of war is the height of idiocy
there's some shifts that have been shut
down at plants and by the way there are
other bridges that go from canada into
the united states and and back so this
is not a massive hardship it doesn't
help the case of the truckers that if
you're that if people are out of some
hours on the job at a ford plant or
another plant so they might want to
think about that but the very way that
these leaders and these
gassy clatter bags on cnn have handled
this and talked about this exemplifies
why the truckers are protesting and
angry in the first place from the
leaders from trudeau on down obey our
edicts and decrees from on high these
would-be emperors and kings they get
treated as if they're plebes and proles
over and over again
that that it's beneath trudeau to even
sit down and talk to them they don't
deserve to be heard they just they don't
deserve a conference conversation just
vilification from these leaders in
canada and these
individuals on cnn one thing about that
cnn thing she said uh take their gas
slash their tires and then move the
trucks does that [ __ ] not know how
trucks actually operate then if they
don't have gas and their tires are flat
they're not moving anywhere
just one just one more thing these are
the people who moved food and
necessities to all of us some of them
were
a lot of them were not
they were
one thing my friend in ontario said that
they are generally a truck driver
because they are generally regarded
ultra right ruffian oh there you go
i want to agree with you i want to agree
with geraldo this brick blocking this
bridge is wrong because how is justin
trudeau going to get his shoe polish
yeah that's right he's got to put the
black face on right yeah
one of the things they're objecting to
is the
term they want to terminate the digital
tracking and the contract contact
tracing which they're doing on your
iphone you may want to look at it you
haven't agreed to it but go through your
uh settings you're there you're being
treated you bought a loaf of bread or
some
or some advil for your ache and back
because you were sitting on your ass all
day long every day for two years yes you
cnn you got it because of a trucker
thank them rather than sneering okay and
i think we can all agree geraldo's
friend in canada represents all
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else